6,3 millionen infizierte 190.000
verstorben und das ist die traurige
corona bilanz bisher in den usa
nun wurde ein interview mit dem
präsidenten donald trump veröffentlicht
in dem er zugibt die korona gefahr
heruntergespielt zu haben
des interviews bereits von anfang des
jahres und wurde geführt vom
starjournalisten bob woodward
ich habe immer versucht es
herunterzuspielen ich spiele es immer
noch gerne herunter und weil ich nicht
will dass panik ausbricht
es wird über die luft übertragen bob und
das ist immer schlimmer als die
übertragung durch anfassen
man muss ja nichts anfassen richtig aber
die luft du atmest die luft einfach ein
und so wird es übertragen
deswegen ist es recht knifflig es ist
wirklich haltung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren